notre rendez vous quotidien avec le
docteur car le vice président de
l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
dr weiss bonsoir vous êtes d'accord avec
ce qu'on a un tapis docteur barrette
plutôt monsieur le premier ministre qui
viennent parler la cornée quand on pense
bien sûr qu'on est dans une crise grave
mais quand on se compare
il ya des raisons de se consoler à
certains égards à certains égards oui
surtout sur notre épidémiologie ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que le taux
d'hospitalisation est faible au québec
actuellement le nombre de jeux de gens
qui sont aux soins intensifs est
relativement faible et certainement
contrôlable et on a encore des
ressources
malheureusement on a des décès mais si
on regarde les décès au québec en
proportion de notre population et de ce
qui s'est passé dans d'autres pays
je dirais qu'à dater on espère ça va
continuer avec des taux les plus faibles
possibles
on est plus bas qu est ce que sont les
autres pays donc sur cet aspect là je
pense que pour l'instant on a très bien
fait pour tous travailler ensemble
l'objectif c'est que mon doit aller dans
la même direction il ya des ya des
écueils
mais il va falloir surmonter les écueils
entend très bien c'est quand même
encourageant en valeur veulent souligner
que questions du public dr weiss est une
personne infectée est asymptomatique et
donc ne pousse pas ou ne ternit pas
comment peut-elle alors transmettent le
virus virus dans sa gorge dans ces voies
aériennes donc dans son dans son système
respiratoire dans son la règle dans sa
trachée danse à la gorge dans son
rhinopharynx cette personne-là peut
avoir du virus en quantité relativement
peut-être plus faibles et quand elle va
parler donc en parlant elle va émettre
des couplets et s'écoute laisse là vont
être respirer par des personnes non pour
tours qui vont les
ils vont les aspirer qui après ça
pourrait développer l'infection donc
même si vous êtes assez symptomatique ça
veut pas dire ya zéro virus dans votre
système respiratoire très bien partira
pas ce débat là sur les masques on en a
beaucoup parlé hier on en reparlera mais
ce qui fait déjà pour prévenir non pas
soi même et les autres autour le port de
masque encore faut-il carney
comme je vous dis on en reparlera il y
at il une différence marquante beaucoup
de courriels là dessus on en a déjà
parlé ensemble entre les souches
est ce la souche initial apparemment et
l souche plus virulente
et quelle souche est plus fréquent
touquet au québec et au canada
la souche la plus fréquente on ne sait
pas encore mais c'est probablement la
même souche qui circule partout sur la
planète et qui est la souche je vous
dirais la plus commune par contre c'est
pas tellement important parce que en
réalité ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
pourquoi certaines personnes vont
développer une maladie pour toi pourquoi
certaines personnes vont développer une
maladie sévère et aussi pourquoi
certaines personnes vont développer les
complications pulmonaires extrêmes donc
ça dans tout le monde recherche
il ya probablement une composante
génétique le deuxième point on en a un
peu parlé hier ce virus-là lui il va
s'adapter à l'espèce humaine est plus
une espèce humaine va s'adapter au virus
le virus risque entre entre guillemets à
la limite de devenir peut-être un peu
moins dangereux pour l'ensemble de la
population
parce que comme je vous dis le virus est
un objectif s'est infectée le plus de
gens cotisent pour perpétuer son cycle
et continuer de se reproduire un virus
qui est trop dangereux qui tue trop de
monde tue son hôte et donc n'est plus
capable d'infecter d'autres personnes
rapidement donc cette année qui vivent
ce fait il ya besoin de nous comme on
disait hier en tout cas y avoir réussi à
lancer une profonde réflexion sur la
manière dont on vit dont on produit que
c'est quand on voyage sur la planète
mais là on n'a pas de réussite
mi janvier j'étais terriblement malades
écrit jonathan je noie quartier un
vomissement c'est vrai que cet art etc
je n'ai pas voyager est ce possible que
j'ai été atteint de lakovic 19 avant que
ça ne devienne la pandémie qu'on connaît
donc mi-janvier de style auquel moi je
vous dirais c'est peu probable parce que
à la mi temps à envier par contre québec
il y avait beaucoup de grip beaucoup
d'influencé donc il ya de fortes chances
que ce soit plutôt l'influenza que
l'acolyte 19 parce que sinon on aurait
trouvé chez d'autres personnes
à ce moment là et on voyait qu'il avait
pas d'activité au québec dont fort peu
probable
non
une question que j'aime beaucoup parce
qu'elle vient d'un enfant de 12 ans
j'encourage les enfants qui sont à la
maison nous écrire et demander à leurs
parents nous écrire
quelle est la différence ça va vous
renvoyer à wancourt docteur entre virus
et microbes et bactéries
ok alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'un microbe en général c'est un mot
commun alors on parle plutôt de
micro-organismes si on va être plus
précis mais un micro organisme -
microbes
ça inclut différentes sortes de choses
avec lui des parasites à l'affût des
champignons ça inclut des bactéries et
ça inclut des virus la grosse différence
entre les bactéries et les virus et les
bactéries sont à peu près 1000 fois plus
grosse que les virus parfois même plus
et les bactéries sont capables de se
multiplier son vivant ring back mais
tout le monde est vivant mais les
bactéries n'ont pas besoin d'un autre
pour pouvoir se multiplier dont vous
prenez une bactérie vous la mettez sur
une tare vous la mettez sur une plante
elle va pouvoir se multiplier par
elle-même un virus va avoir besoin d'une
cellule pour pouvoir se multiplier
on va utiliser la cellule de quelque
chose d'autre pour se multiplier les
virus n'ont pas l'autonomie que les
bactéries au bon dieu vous êtes bon dr
val je vous aime beaucoup
est ce qu'il y à des exercices de
respiration en terminant que nous
pourrions pratiques et de maintenant et
qui contribuerait à renforcer notre
capacité pulmonaire
si oui lesquels bah écoutez je vais vous
dire que le meilleur exercice que vous
pouvez faire c'est d'arrêter de fumer
pour ceux qui tuent c'est le meilleur
exercice que vous pouvez faire c'est
vraiment le moment de faire ça si vous
en avez l'occasion et vous allez avoir
fait le meilleur exercice quant aux
autres je vous dirais il n'y a pas
vraiment d'exercice particulier c'est
sûr que les gens qui sont en forme qui
font du sport ont souvent des capacités
pulmonaires global meilleur là je sais
que mes collègues ne me lave n'aimeront
pas quand j'utilise le mot capacité
pulmonaire totale parce qu'en médecine 5
particularités mais revenir au ventre
donner tout ce que je veux dire c'est
quand vous êtes en forme et si vous
utilisez ça et ça va bien aller très
bien
il ya un brouillard devant vous c'est
presque une oeuvre impressionniste dr
weiss on se retrouve demain merci
beaucoup encore une fois un peu plus
voir et revoir